l'artiste est un traité artistes donc
est bien connu des gens du domaine de la
rue notamment en région parisienne et en
particulier dans val de marne
du côté d'ivry et vitry qui a un
graffeur qui reconnut qui travaille au
pochoir
le but était de parler de science en
essayant d'avoir un vecteur et un
discours différent de celui qui habituel
on voulait sortir de la vulgarisation
scientifique
essayez aussi de toucher d'autres
publics ce qui était déjà acquis par les
sciences donc on peut raconter
d'histoires qui a presque l'histoire
d'amour de marie curie avec pierre curie
on peut raconter la difficulté
historique pas avoir quelqu'un comme
eisenberg parce qu'ils étaient proches
du régime nazi raconte l'histoire de
rosalind franklin qui a réalisé des
images qui prouvait la structure en
double hélice de l'adn même qu'il a été
volé entre guillemets par deux hommes de
cette découverte qu'une prix nobel alors
qu'elle est même pas sifflé pour les
discours nobel n'avait envie de raconter
des histoires et à travers ces histoires
de par les tic
sa technique est complètement exploité
ici si ce n'est que le gros apport de ce
travail en commun ça a été deux
d'ajouter de la profondeur et du sens à
son travail là où une représentation
dans la rue en vitrine dans le xiiième
d'un chat est avec une seule valeur
esthétique d'animation de la rue ici ça
devient le chat de schrödinger et ça
permet de parler de la mécanique
quantique sa part être le maître d'art
et d'histoire des sciences et de choses
qui peuvent être paradoxal on a essayé
de coller à des personnages qui sont en
rapport avec le cea saclay donc il ya
beaucoup de physique
donc on commence par l' expertise
française dans le domaine du nucléaire
qui vient de henri becquerel marie curie
marie curie pierre curie en me mettrais
de la famille curie aussi avec irène et
frédéric et ça s'est ensuite étendu
jusqu'à deux figures historiquement
importante pour le césar comme jean
perrin le général de gaulle
frédéric joliot des scientifiques
importants actuellement pour
l'université paris saclay grabherr faire